foreign
when it came to playing the blues there
was no other musician quite as gifted as
Robert Johnson his powerful vocals and
unrivaled skill at the guitar were
nothing other than extraordinary he was
good too good shortly after his death at
the age of 27 rumors began to spread
about the origin of Robert Johnson's
Talent he had made a deal with Satan he
sold his soul to become the greatest
musician of the Mississippi Delta
throughout history there are many
curious Tales of people who gain
unimaginable wealth and talent under
suspicious circumstances if the Legends
are to be believed the price tag is a
lifetime of loyalty and servitude to the
devil but when it comes to selling your
soul for Earthly gain there's a lot you
ought to think about I'd hate for you to
enter a diabolical contract uninformed
so I've drafted up a helpful list of
pros and cons of selling your soul to
Demons using examples taken from history
warning setting assault nipple has
severe physical and spiritual
repercussions side effects include but
not limited II Eternal damnation
possible great doom and or Gloom nausea
and a lifetime observative defense of
Darkness please consult with the
parental legal guardian put undertaking
faster bargain of your own YouTube
videos cannot be held as valid evidence
of Supernatural okay on with the video
have you ever wanted more out of life
feel like you're missing out on the
wealth power and knowledge you deserve
well a deal with the devil might just be
your ticket to happiness just think
you're one small signature away from
acquiring a new skill without the boring
hours of practice or finding that
perfect romantic partner without the
hassle of self-improvement the
possibilities seem endless but be warned
nothing good comes for free consider the
legend of Dr Faustus perhaps the most
famous example of selling one soul for
personal gain in one version of the
popular myth Faustus was a scholar who
had become dissatisfied with his work
he'd always felt that there was more to
his studies than just law logic and
science it's at that moment when a demon
suddenly appears in his Chambers
introducing himself as Mephistopheles he
had been observing Faustus and offered
him him all the knowledge he desires the
catch his soul without adequately
weighing up the risks Faustus agrees to
the deal Mephistopheles will serve
Faustus for 24 years but once those
years are up the devil will claim his
soul for eternity the demon
Mephistopheles teaches Faustus
everything he had desired and more
including the dark arts of magic Alchemy
and divination Faustus soon finds
himself with unfathomable riches and
wondrous new powers which he enjoys for
24 Blissful years inevitably however
those years trickle away the story ends
with fauster's bitterly regretting his
decision but it's too late the devil has
come to claim what is owed the tragic
story of Faustus appears in plays books
and films the tale contains a warning
Beware of the dangers of ambition had
Faustus accepted the feeble limits of
human knowledge he may have been happier
in the long run but in the short term
those perks are pretty sweet think of
all the good you can do with all the
knowledge in the world think of all the
bad you can do to play devil's advocate
here is an eternity in Hell really worth
it if religious art is anything to go by
it looks like a pretty unpleasant place
to visit demonic torture bubbling
cauldrons and being chewed on by Satan
himself there's a lot to have to put up
with but don't let these artworks
discourage you after all how would these
painters know what hell is actually like
it's not like they've been there
themselves
unless the story of Dr Faustus is
fictional but there are real life cases
of individuals who are alleged to have
made a pact with the devil often they
are musicians Nicolo Paganini was one of
the most celebrated violinists of his
day he was a virtuoso a title given to
the rare few who had total Mastery of
their instrument Paganini was the best
of the best and regularly filled out
concert Halls across Europe many
wondered how he became so talented
perhaps it was his abnormally long hands
which allowed him to play three octaves
or his tendency to wildly dance around
the stage when pakanini died at the age
of 57 rumors spread that he had made a
bargain with demons one Court goer from
Vienna claimed to see the devil in the
audience others thought Paganini was the
Devil Himself as the Scandal grew
priests refused to bury the violinist it
was a further 20 years for Paganini to
find a permanent resting place if the
stories are to be believed Satan has a
good ear for music and just like in the
music industry today he encourages
musicians to enter into unfair contracts
just look at the many musical genres
throughout history that have been
labeled the devil's music rock and roll
hip-hop Jazz folk the waltz I don't know
about you but hell has a pretty great
soundtrack in fact if you listen
carefully you may actually hear Satan in
the music there's a particular
combination of notes that's been
nicknamed diabolous in Musica Latin 4
devil in the music it's called a tritone
a combination of three adjacent whole
tones and it sounds a bit like this
foreign
the tritone has an eerie dissonant sound
no wonder it was forbidden in church
music over the years this daunting chord
has been used to conjure up an image of
Hell listen to this extract from the
Dante Symphony by Franz list in which he
uses tritones throughout
[Applause]
foreign foreign
[Music]
the suspicion of these tritones persists
even today in fact they were often used
in the blues music of Robert Johnson who
we met in the introduction his devilish
sounds likely fueled the suspicion that
he had sold his soul to the devil
for those who want knowledge wealth and
power at any cost a soul seems like a
bargain but what does Satan get out of
it all why is he so interested in
collecting human souls in many Christian
Traditions Satan is described as being
in competition with God who can command
the most Souls who can influence world
affairs for much of History it was
believed that Satan and his demonic
Representatives roamed the Earth and
prayed on the weak of heart sometimes
these religious fears would erupt into a
mass moral Panic like with the witch
trials that spread across early modern
Europe and the Americas Ordinary People
predominantly women were accused of
making secret pacts with the devil and
using their magical powers to cause
droughts plagues and general Misfortune
it was said that they would gather late
at night to perform a Sabbath a dark
ritual where
would be summoned to walk the earth
there are many witchcraft books from
this era like the Lesser key of Solomon
a compendium of demons it also contains
advice on how to summon them at home you
find a demon who can help you with a
given issue
etch their sigil in chalk and negotiate
a fair prize to counter the apparent
rise in witchcraft came the dedicated
witch Hunters agents of the church who
would go around accusing people of
sorcery however actually proving the
local milkmaid is secretly a client of
Satan is difficult if not impossible so
the witch Hunters used whatever they
could as evidence forced confessions
torture and even finding incriminating
birthmarks if they got what they were
looking for the punishment was typically
being burnt alive at the stake the witch
hunts claimed up to 60 000 innocent
lives and sometimes even priests would
get caught up in the accusations Urbane
grantier was a French priest accused of
the ludan possessions image a group of
local nuns accused him of bewitching
their Convent a trial quickly ensued and
a mysterious piece of evidence was
brought forward an alleged contract with
the devil in an encrypted Latin script
the document claims that grantier had
bargained his soul in exchange for money
power and women as a result the priest
was later burned at the stake after his
death many grew suspicious of this
mystery contract nowadays it's believed
that it was politically motivated by his
enemies in the church my advice is this
when it comes to making a deal with the
devil be wary that your newfound Powers
don't Garner any suspicion it's hard to
enjoy yourself when the Inquisition is
at your door if you do happen to sign a
satanic contract or have a diabolical
birthmark best keep that evidence to
yourself as we've seen the myth of
making a deal with the devil appears in
many different places but where does it
come from one of the earliest stories
has to do with a book in the Middle Ages
ironically a copy of the Bible the Codex
gigas literally meaning big book is the
largest medieval manuscript in existence
turning to folio 290 there's a
frightening illustration of a crouching
devil adorned with sharp claws and a
forked tongue this image has sparked
numerous creative tales about where it
came from one story is that it was
created by an unknown monk in a dire
situation the monk had broken his
monastic Valves and was due to be buried
alive in a last ditch effort to escape
this fate he promised to write out the
entire Bible in a single night what he
produced was the Codex gigas a book so
large and intricate that is estimated to
have taken 20 years to have been written
according to Legend he'd asked the devil
for some assistance that night and Drew
a nice picture of him as a way of saying
thanks the moral of the story at least I
think is that if you need help getting
work done dial a demon the inspiration
for these myths come from the Christian
New Testament to the story of Jesus
wandering the desert in the biblical
account Satan appears before Jesus to
tempt him into following him the
Temptation Of Christ is the foundation
behind the concept of making a demonic
pact Satan is depicted as a tempter who
can promise worldly things all for a
little bit of everlasting Allegiance is
that too much to ask for Christians
Jesus provides an example of how to
react to this kind of demonic temptation
just say no even if it isn't as fun the
concept of selling your soul to the
devil has been used in a variety of ways
throughout history to warn people of the
dangers of greed and ambition to account
for people with extraordinary abilities
or to persecute an individual or whole
group of the population it's a mixed bag
for sure and the mythological Trope
certainly has had a complicated history
whether or not such things actually
exist is a matter of personal belief but
on the off chance it happens to you here
are the pros and cons of making a pact
with Satan on the pro side we have
getting a promotion at work learning a
new musical instrument generating a
creative source of income finishing a
project for a deadline on the con side
you risk
Eternal damnation a life in servitude to
the dark lord paperwork risk of being
burned at the stake these are the things
that you may want to consider when faced
with a austian bargain of your own you
may find that being satisfied with what
you already have in life is good enough
perhaps wealth status and ambition are
overrated especially when demons are
involved I'll let you figure out what's
best I know which one I prefer
hey thanks for watching I really hope
you enjoyed this one if you like this
video and want to see more why not
subscribe a like and a comment also go a
really long way in case you don't know
I've made an investigative series The
Interruption available to listen
wherever you get your podcasts oh and do
check out the Channel's merch over at
crowdmade we have beanies t-shirts and
hoodies links are in the description
down below anyway I look forward to
seeing you next time
goodbye